illegally before the announcements  were made as honorable again beautiful  went to the left hand again that's twice  with the finish with the left  it's really unusual isn't it he  basically is a righty  dribbles with the right hand but on the  side he goes to the left  setting it up that was a pass  too that was not a shot there by trey  young  wow and it's a full point atlanta lead  that's last touch by capella it'll be  box ball young knew that collins was  going to roll  hard all along so he threw this  above the square and let the athleticism  of collins do the rest  that is a beautiful play there by young  that is absolutely an assist  it's a 19-8 run here by the hawks  off the